so has added a school to brand victory
with Germany's world cup win and how do
economic and sporting success depend on
one another let's discuss this now with
ours three new guests of the week too
much now power from the Hamburg
Institute of International Economics
good to have you with us and of course
first of all I have to ask you where did
you watch the final and did you wear a
jersey no i didn't i watch it at home
with friends and it was a pleasure it
was exciting it was a thrill to watch
such a game and happily enough at the
end right team won ok so you did not
spend you didn't go ad on a spending
spree buying the flags and everything
like that so because we've seen the
report that a lot of people are doing
that of course and now with euphoria of
having won the title how do you think
this will affect the German economy
positively I mean economics has
something to do with psychology and such
a win makes a meeting German even more
worthwhile than before also to the
outside just outside of course and
inside Germany it gives the feel of
community that everybody is a member of
this champion team and so I think this
has contributed to this so called the
social capital that it could talk about
something in the morning we have an
issue everybody can talk about it in the
same level the chief as and the staff
are all experts so I think this is a
positive feeling for germany it has a
positive effect on the economy also
certainly on the market value of the
players and the club's will earn a lot
of money and transfer fees what sums are
we talking about you absolutely I I mean
we know already now that some of the
players will move to other teams and
with the highest record transfer sums
and I think this is just the beginning
and I think they have stimulated their
worth by at least a dimension and so I
think they are the most profitable team
players for the moment and somehow money
doesn't seem to run out I mean adidas
has just signed a an advertising deal
with the British Premier League club
Manchester United of course with 1
billion euros the sky's the limit it
sounds a lot of
money but don't forget that we have a
globalized economy and the more
globalized the economy is the more the
business becomes globalized and also
promotion and commercials and all these
issues that goes along with the team so
with a billion people as fans you have a
lot of potential customers and so I
think this is a merciful for Adidas and
all the others to go in this direction
because there is there are still a
billion more people that may come into
this market in the couple of years to
come